holy bonko's kids look out
the keep it moving tour is adding new
dates
we're coming to a city near you come and
see us
some stand up and we play ayg at the end
of the show
with the crowd we answer your garbage
questions
we've got some trash so far but i know
i know there's deeper garbage out there
around the country
oh yeah so come on out and see us kippy
tell them what they need to know
oh baby we're all over the place uh
providence rhode island
august 11th boston massachusetts august
12th new brunswick new jersey
august 25th down tomatoes timonium
maryland magooby's
august 26th couple of crabs and we're
going to tejas baby
uh september 21st will be in san antonio
texas september 22nd we'll be in houston
texas
september 23rd through the 25th austin
texas for the moon tower comedy festival
and i ain't done yet august 26th will be
at fort dallas fort worth texas what
then we're bringing it back
to long island baby what and all uh
september 30th
and then we're coming home the boys are
the chickens are coming home to roost
baby
october 27th we're gonna be in
philadelphia pennsylvania and then back
down to tejas
uh november 5th through the 7th for
skankfest south get those tickets the
link will be in the description
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r.u
garbage it's a little show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and we find
if they grow to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host stage foley coming
at you
on a beautiful day we're down here in
aunt toddy's basement
she's upstairs yeah fresh bottle of
perks oh yeah
got her set till labor day wow look at
that somewhere to turi there you go my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me he is the ceo of ru garbage ladies
and gentlemen he's a goddamn
international businessman
so show him some respect give it up for
kevin james ryan hey gang happy to be
here as always please make sure you rate
view subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube
patreon.com you sign up you get a bunch
of bonus content and live shows i don't
know
i don't know when this comes out we
there's going to be a bunch of [ __ ]
dates coming out we're going to be all
over the [ __ ] place so
get some tickies to a show you just had
a little respect on the intro for you
because you didn't call me a bozo it's
the end of the month
yeah i know paycheck time yeah i know mr
ryan i'm aware you get real [ __ ] nice
around the 22nd of every month
turn that patreon to getting ready to
process you're like oh mr ryan do you
need a coffee
your hair growing in what's going on
propecia's working gang how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire he's the magic man
former chicago comic recent new york
transplant
hitting the scene hard give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what up dudes hey buddy oh
man
i'm sorry are the numbers going down
cause i think that they're
true to roof i'm sorry i forgot he
called me slipping you caught me
slipping i got
one bit on the show no toby has one toby
has one scripted line and i stole it
from him
oh [ __ ] dude hey toby we're cutting your
intro next week
dang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly and i mean
incredibly special guest here with us
today
for the first time this man is a very
funny stand-up comedian podcaster writer
and actor
you've seen him on conan you've seen him
on this week at the comedy cellar
the stand-up show with john dore and of
course he is the host
of the amazing podcast stand by your
band
but the big question but his mind today
is he garbage i'm gonna tell you
something
this guy came in this is a [ __ ]
precedent set here
walked in with a truly pineapple mango
pounder the big boy that's bigger than a
pound i think that's a 20
that's a 20 that's a dude that's a 24
ounce truly
at 2 p.m i might have it's 2 30.
i want to break i want to break the
[ __ ] fourth wall here it's the
afternoon
on a wednesday or thursday whatever it's
2 45 somewhere
this guy's got a three liter of white
claw in his bag gang give it up for tom
to car
thanks for doing it i was stunned when
you walked in with that yeah i mean
stunned i thought this was a podcast
about being garbage i didn't know you
guys were gonna be so [ __ ] friendly
afternoon on a work week for god's sakes
i've been wanting to drink more during
the podcast to be honest yeah i
i was i thought that uh everybody would
be partying here i thought certainly
what's this [ __ ] job over there come
on pop one baby
get crazy toby's got a bit of a problem
you hear that hippie
you hear that hippie you look like a
dirt ball that's what he's saying
well you know some things change
chemical addictions happen
yeah toby's straight edge now anybody
who's a christian in chicago is like
they boo they get out my buddy came here
and they were like i don't know whatever
he's talking about people in new york
drink and then they realized everybody
they were with
was from chicago yeah yeah yeah i
remember well
in other cities other than new york when
you like you drink that's
part of comedy a lot it's like you go do
one set and then you get drunk it's like
a big social thing
sure and i remember i moved up here and
i was like i was a big drinker i was at
the bar and i ordered a picture for
myself because i'm like
it was cheaper than going up and getting
your ears and i turn around and monroe
martin and eric kanes were like
who's that for i'm like me they're like
you can't be doing this up here yeah i'm
like all right i'm sorry i thought we
were partying that's what people in
chicago there was a bar i don't know if
it was around when you were doing it but
there used to be an open mic where it
was
two dollar pictures and so you would go
and you'd go
late and it sucked [ __ ] but you were
like i am [ __ ] up
it's a good night i'm a successful
comedian
i love that that was my favorite part
yeah i'll struggle through five minutes
and then 15 beers let's go
the more you drink the better your
career feels yeah yeah
pictures are garbage yeah off the jump i
agree
i'm a big fan now i agree because it's
going to go flat faster
i like i like a draft or or a bottle i i
love a bottle of high life is maybe
it's pretty ice cold nothing wrong with
a highlight yes nothing wrong with a
highlight if you're getting a picture
most chances are the bar is not cleaning
the lines no it's a plastic
[ __ ] that's always play if you're
going through nowhere no one's serving a
glass pitcher
by the way because if you're drinking
pictures they're going to get thrown at
some point you go to a really good chuck
e cheese they'll throw
they'll throw a picture of birch beer at
you in a glass pitcher i'm a big picture
guy
if you got like four people at a table
just like two pictures at a time and
they're going quick if you're like
watching a game or something
that came out that's fair i still would
rather just a bucket of beers if i'm
gonna do something like that
that's the mark of a gentleman right
there a bucket of beer bucket of beers
is where i like to live you know
baker's dozen of rolling rocks ponies
yeah [ __ ] ice down
yeah the beer tower is the trashiest
movie oh yeah
that's another thing this is so i grew
up in a college town
uh i'd like that uh when i grew up i was
like oh my god it's
it's it's you're losing money not to
drink wait wait wait
wait it's a beer tower a beer tower
there's like big things like a hundred
ounces yeah hundred ounces they had a
hundred ounce craft beer
ten dollars at this mexican place in my
hometown i'm moving to indy you got to
move to you got to move to bloomington
indiana brother
and it's my buddy yeah but in
bloomington miller lights craft beer
come on
come on now don't come at my home
yeah is light we don't take that commie
[ __ ] over you gotta pay that right now
we were at a bowling alley with a tower
of beers my buddy was blacked out with
his calculator out
being like they got to be ripping us off
this deal is good i've done that a lot
break out the calculator to make sure
the ounces line up
oh yeah half of this is just sprite
what's going on you're doing you're
taking inventory like you had one he had
two that one's halfway done
they're shorter that's nine ounces here
again place like that
one thing's for certain those things
have never and will never be washed no
because you would have to
do anything yeah there's not a sink big
enough to get that no
they just like you know yeah no way holy
[ __ ] so give us the complete backstory
because i said i was a little in the
dark about this now you mentioned
indiana yes take it from there give us
the deets
so i'm from i'm from bloomington indiana
cougar melontown that's right
yeah he piece of [ __ ] by the way really
bad reputation bad reputation in
bloomington yeah he's not
getting a bunch of [ __ ] hot chicks i
can imagine i mean he did bring meg ryan
which is weird
but i love meg ryan i love meg ryan too
he was dating meg ryan
he's still with meg ryan i believe
johnny cougar i'm pretty sure he's man
they live in bloomington indiana but he
has a bet he's the type to like not tip
well at chili's and [ __ ]
really yeah yeah and like him there's a
story
uh my sister told me this where we have
a shoe
place in indiana called shoe carnival
clearly not a high-class place
it's but it's where we would go to get
our shoes the shoe carnies in town
and wait is it a year-round store yes
yes it's not like a car traveling do you
walk into like a clown's mouth or
something what's the carnival
it's they only sell clown shoes what
size are you little fella
so there's this place called shoe
carnival you get to spin a wheel that
gives you a discount or something it's
it's pretty fun honestly but i holy
yeah you're spinning the wheel of shoes
yeah that's the wheel of shame
they didn't have like nikes they just
have like shack shoes and [ __ ] like
shoes shock shoes are a tough look they
had the and ones that were like nobody
wanted
yeah i loved it there were two left
shoes
[Laughter]
so he rolls into shoe carnival which
you're like you're a [ __ ] celebrity
ballpark what are we talking about we're
not talking about 90s 80s are we
this is uh probably early 2000s i want
to say maybe late 90s i
i i drink a lot my timeline no you no
way never picked up on that
so he rolls in there he sees a pair of
shoes he wants
they don't have it in his size he pulls
do you know who i
am carnival as if they're going to be
like oh
my bad let's take you to the celebrity
room of
shoe corner why don't you say something
well that attitude is probably why meg
ryan left his ass in november
2019. let's go
on the market back out on the market i
love
meg ryan yeah city of angels great movie
check it out
the quote is it got exhausting for her
to deal with
yes if you're meg ryan and you're dating
you're
with melon camp he takes you to
applebee's you're like
i did not think this is what it was
going to be also she shouldn't be dating
anybody that's shopping at [ __ ] shoe
corners yes you know what i mean
he's a steak well done guy too oh i'm
sure
give me some ketchup give me the ketchup
that's already loose
i don't want to have to
do you know who i am you bring me the i
got to put a knife in here
[Laughter]
darling give me an open bottle all right
that made me think of something i lost
it [ __ ] it's
alcohol poisoning
it's got wet brain over here i've been
living loose brother
my lady was out of town for two weeks
that'll get you it's it's i've had that
happen and you're
just like saying my lady's trash dude
damn this guy's hitting all cylinders
yeah it's a cowbell
what motorcycle kangaroo that's fancy in
indiana that's good
yeah old ladies the trash
yeah i don't like pop for dad bothers me
oh
i'm like who what are you doing that's
why i didn't have a dad
because then you don't have to worry
about sounding trashy this guy's playing
chess over here
everyone else is figuring out what to
call their dad he just eliminates the
problem
all right give us the scoop uh born in
bloomington indiana
no dad i picked up on that read that
between the lines
i had a stepdad but not a you know he
wasn't like a good uh
person so
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
there's no beginning so i was born on a
tuesday
shoe carnival was a good place to start
that was a good intro uh
all right so your stepdad what ages were
you when he would do so i was like
so i he came around when i was like two
he was new he was because
my parents were never married my my
father was an indian man
who uh went to prison shortly after i
was okay
wait pin in the step dad why didn't he
go to prison i don't want to get too
injured okay
it's a lot of [ __ ] that uh my mom
prefers me not to talk about
i think we totally can't talk about it
not a great person but uh you know he he
didn't want to be a dad
i was half white he was like embarrassed
by that and then
my white family was like he's half about
me they're like he's half indian he's a
[ __ ]
so my stepdad comes in uh pretty much
immediately
he's like he's around he's a booze bag
no brothers and sisters
i have five brothers and sisters but
they're all weird they're all over the
place my mom had kids when she was 13.
so holy [ __ ] so uh that's my older
sibling can we release this
[Laughter]
legally could we get any trouble please
tell me
please tell me their dad was a 13 year
old uh
don't ask questions you're not ready
you're not ready to hear the answer
this might have to be a patreon episode
no no no
hold on let's just slow it down a little
bit so dude what
i say we speed it up i
this kid came in throwing [ __ ] 101
out of the gate
you're like you were like i want to hear
your whole backstory i was like i don't
think you do
we we all 20 minutes from now
in the corner i've also legit forgot
about the step dad getting drunk and
staying in the front yard
oh yeah all right just just so i have my
time left so you're two years old
now are there other kids already in the
house so there are but they're already
kind of like i mean my brother was
somebody who ran away from
the house when he was like thirteen two
he's like every character they get
introduced we go off on another team
yeah i feel like we're all gonna get
tattoos by the end of this
[Laughter]
yeah they're uh they're all over the
place but my
sister was still in the house i
shouldn't have belched into the mic but
i think it's already answered if i'm
trash or whatever yeah this the rest is
yeah formalities i don't know you that
well i just thought you're like a nice
clean guy
so did i i'm a good guy yeah of course i
just
yeah i didn't expect this yeah that's
correct you carry yourself at least from
you know distance as a nice refined
you know totally you know subdued man
this is bonkers are you guys in a house
we're in a house oh we're in an
apartment actually when i was really
little and then when i was about four we
we moved to the woods and
let me catch my breath we moved to like
a little like kind of farmer area
where we were like yeah in the country
or whatever out of the suburbs of
indiana
like a place you go now and it's like
trump 20 20 flags everywhere
uh because it's like i said it's a
college town but we were not in that
part
um so we're in college yeah yeah no no
no no correspondence courses going on
uh yeah it's uh it's it's a weird area
but
so i had older siblings still kind of
around but then i became the oldest one
in the house pretty
quick and then i had uh three younger
siblings with the stepdad
that two with the stepdad one adopted
okay so you're so your mom and stepdad
adopted a kid yeah that's nice was it
was it for
tax purposes no no but uh there are
other people in my family who i could
say
okay all right all right chicken
sandwich
um pictures over there
those [ __ ] guys on mockingbird lane
[Laughter]
all right nuts so that's the that's
basically the nuclear family at the time
of your growing up
it's me as like the older brother and
then i have uh three years
as a nuclear family i think it's a
spider web of trash
nuclear like like [ __ ] blast zone
[ __ ] it we're not talking about two
people mom and dad at 2.5 kids with a
picket fence
we're talking about woods people dad
arrives home from work around five
o'clock and the kids are playing in the
front yard
okay okay hot dude i'm [ __ ]
what did your mom do what did your
stepdad do so when i was a kid my mom
worked at red lobster
that's why we were in bloomington she
managed a red lobster
she was damn good at it too but does
your family crest a switchblade in a bud
light
no we were a natural light family sir
what are we what are we [ __ ] one
percenters he just said
my mom worked in a red lobster that's
why we were in bloomington
i thought i go oh maybe the corporate's
there or something you gotta go we just
still worked at a branch you gotta go
with the cheddar biscuits are you know
what i mean she had to move for a
lobster
they were like it's either you move or
you gotta you're fired is that true
or like she they were like we were
opening this branch we want you to
manage it
she was a man she became a manager they
actually make these
they did all right yeah she would she
would work ships though and she my mom
is a hustler and she said she's a nurse
practitioner now she like truly is like
a miracle of a story because she had
kids when she was 13.
she came from a huge family worked her
way out of poverty
in college that's [ __ ] amazing thank
god we got a break yeah
silver lining holy
[ __ ] yeah so so she started working at
the hospital i was a kid
she's like working like 60 70 80
it done making sure we have food no
mouths and [ __ ] uh
because my stepdad was a [ __ ] dumbass
and like
he was he worked at an oil change place
that was next to the red lobster which i
think is how they met
i don't ask a lot of questions sure sure
uh you're pretty hot if you ask me
that sounds that's like a john cougar
song
that's little person tip at the red
lobster
really
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
despite his poor gratuity habits
and ill manners at the shoe carnival i
think i think
jack and diane was the first song i
remember remembering
does that make sense the hell does that
mean i mean what the [ __ ] remember
remembering
you remember you're in the matrix
brother is this inception
no like that was like the first song i
remember hearing yeah yeah
okay his memory of music was that all
right yeah memorizing that
okay this guy's judging me remember
all right all right um
do you see why i had to bring a beer i'm
upset you didn't bring
six i grossly underestimated you i love
it
holy cow all right so then your nurse
your mom's a nurse practitioner at this
point oh yeah define what did that
happen in college though oh that's what
we're working on yes
so she's she becomes a nurse when i was
like maybe seven or something like that
okay
she starts yeah she starts working she's
doing she's doing good stuff but
stepdad's not doing anything he is a oil
change guy he's working he's still
working there
we weren't still yeah but uh you know
he's
he's home a lot she's not are they
together still now
they are okay okay uh yeah like so again
can't get two sure just you're just
trying to just trying to check the
innocence
yeah yeah of course um all right so then
where does
it come in that he gets drunk and stands
in the front yard that was about a once
a month thing because he would get drunk
all the time
but uh he i couldn't do [ __ ] at night it
would if i wanted to like play
basketball like on the team or whatever
one i would got cut but also
i couldn't do it because i he would have
to be my ride and he was like i can't
drive at night but
he said it was his vision it's like no
you were hammered it was nice it was the
13 splits
like when he took he taught me to drive
and he was like
you're driving too suspiciously because
he had a beer
he had a beer in the car you got to
swerve a little bit
what does that do to the psychology of
of a driver when you learn to drive
drink truly to 2 15. 2 45.
if we ever pull bank job you're the
wheel man gang this podcast is brought
to you by our good friends
at betterhelp oh yeah uh better help
want you to take care of your mental
health we want you to take care of your
mental health that's why if you use
better help they can evaluate you and
they can assign you a professional
licensed therapist
that you could be talking to within 48
hours from the privacy
of your own home listen guys we're all
little bonkos everybody knows that
you gotta talk to somebody you know what
i mean i started talking to somebody it
helps a lot and with better help
uh you can start communicating under 48
hours it's not a crisis hotline it's not
a self-help hotline
it's professional counseling done
securely online
uh there's a broad range of expertise
available uh that may not be available
locally if you're in a small town or
whatever you can get the help that you
need
um it's available to clients worldwide
so for our uh you know our foreign
listeners
that good old american health care that
we all know uh it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available if you need
it
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today you can visit their
website read the testimonials the whole
nine yards
uh but if you visit betterhelp.com
garbage that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p and join over the one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
uh in fact so many people are using
better help they're recruiting um
counselors in all 50 states there you go
even alaska in hawaii baby they're
growing i mean uh special offer
for are you garbage listeners you get 10
off your first month
there you go i ain't talking one week i
ain't talking one time i'm talking your
whole money they want you to get better
who doesn't so go to betterhealth.com
garbage yeah high school what was that
like oh man it sucked it was
i was thinking about i didn't think it
was going to be like saved by the bell
yeah it turns out that sort of
background doesn't make you
a social butterfly nobody relates to
your weird stories
and my stepdad would like make me listen
to his [ __ ] music all the time he'd
get drunk he'd be like
you gotta hear this song he'd have me up
to like three in the morning
because he's like partying but he
doesn't have any friends he's partying
with you yeah yeah
i'm the i'm the guy who's like he's like
thinks we're having fun
but he's like you gotta listen he got me
into like journey and ac dc and [ __ ]
that's pretty good
the other kids at school didn't give a
[ __ ] about that yeah i remember the
teacher was like you guys probably
haven't heard a journey and i was like i
raised my hand i was like
i like journaling i got tickets next
month
yeah listening to him last night in the
kitchen at 4 am
all right holy [ __ ] single family home
apartment you said uh then we moved into
a house oh yeah yeah
so we yeah we moved to a house when i
was like five or something like that
okay timeline's hazy i was a booze bag
as a kid
and that was the wood house or no no no
no i didn't start drinking until i was
like 22. no i guess i start
i didn't really start having drinks
until i was like 22-23 because i had a
i went through a broken engagement when
i was 22 and then i just
i decided i was like i'm going to be
like in a movie i'm going to live like a
movie character who
gets out of a bad relationship okay
start drinking whiskey yeah and i made
myself like it now it's uh you know
a problem um
you got engaged at 22. i got engaged i
was 21-22
high school sweetheart uh no it was a
college
uh slash co-worker uh that i was uh
what was the job i worked at the
hospital when i was 18 i moved out and i
got a job at the hospital that my mom
worked at okay in the emergency
department as like an insurance
like i would get people's insurance
information in the hospital and uh
so we met while i was doing that and i
like i lost a bunch of weight i got my
confidence up i was living alone i you
know i just started doing comedy
and uh and so i met this girl and uh
we yeah she moved to ohio we got engaged
when i graduated i moved to ohio to live
with her and it fell apart
immediately it was it was crashed and
burned so fast because she was in med
school
and i'm just an [ __ ] driving to
columbus ohio to do
open mics every night right yeah it was
uh huh
where'd you go to school did you go to i
went to you yeah yeah i went to the
school in my hometown because it was
cheaper you know indiana university
yeah okay yeah all right yep
okay nice little school and you
graduated i graduated
okay just checked and did it just
checked i did it i think i was the first
like
i was the first like member of my like
local like my family to
to graduate from college wow i probably
first want to get into
yeah or apply i think at that matter it
doesn't sound again stiff competition
you were number one two and three in
your class um
what'd you get on your sats that's a
good because so i did sats when they
were doing that goofy [ __ ] where you had
to do the hundreds
it was like yeah 2400 or something like
that 24 yeah you're right yeah
and i do 24. i i did all right yeah i
was i was a good student as a kid i was
trying to go to med school
and then i you know got sucked into
comedy and so
uh the more i did comedy i was like
there's no [ __ ] way no way that could
happen yeah be a doctor
but uh yeah i did all right i think i
got like if you're not counting that
essay thing i think i got like a twelve
hundred dollars
good that's good gpa in high school high
it was pretty high
it wasn't like a four but it was like
three point seven or some [ __ ] like that
what schools did you apply to
school
i hated the idea of having debt like i
didn't want to have to take out a bunch
of loans and [ __ ]
and like i had some child support money
left over i only got one child support
payment from my
my father who was a doctor he gave us
one sum of money just to be like
all right that's it that's all you're
getting when was this when you were
young
uh it was right before i turned 18. we
because we had to hunt it down
it was 10 grand for my entire childhood
okay and
we just put that towards college nice
yeah
all right step dad didn't griften on you
that's cool
he's all hopped up on oil who knows
it's 10 w20 in the veins just out of
curiosity raised
any religion catholic christian and we
tried catholic my
mighty tries catholic the problem is
like i don't know if this is what it is
but i've kind of speculated so my mom
had been divorced already you know she
had kids
my my also i had a bad history with
religion right off the bat because my
stepdad's mom was our babysitter
and i wasn't baptized and i was a
bastard child i was born out of wedlock
she was like you're going to hell
like you're a bastard child so i was
like immediately like well i guess
[ __ ] me like yeah what are you talking
about i got nothing to lose
hey honey how about some dunkaroos in
the jetsons will you [ __ ] see
the bricks don't talk there was never a
moment where it was like and you can get
out she was like i mean you should
probably get baptized
maybe that'll help i don't know it was
like fox so we went to catholic church
but we
we didn't fit in and then when i was
like 16 i started going to
baptist church because i played
basketball with a bunch of
baptists and they sucked me in they were
like they were like we got to play
basketball in the baptist church like in
the league
and like i was a fat kid i couldn't make
my high school team so i was like hell
yeah i can finally play
and then just one night they were like
we gotta talk to you buddy uh
have you been saved and i was like god
damn it i just wanted to play basketball
and then i did that for two years and
then uh bailed you were baptized
i did get baptized yeah yeah now you're
in indiana you do that in the river or
we did it in the church yeah there was
just a tub uh
in our church i [ __ ] hated this place
it was like a tan it was like a it was
like a fish
yeah it was someone's like someone's
throwing [ __ ] baseballs at them
you got baptized carnival carnival you
only get salvation if i can hit this
target
i got five tickets bunch of goldfish in
there with you
we only got one tank
holy yeah yeah so i did get baptized uh
when i was like
when i was like 17 yeah it's so weird to
think of too
that's a that's a yeah that's the memory
that's crazy
oh man i apologize but yeah i thought
this should have been lighter
buddy this is the [ __ ] meat of it i
just
this is our super bowl dude yeah i just
also think that
our perspective of because we're you
know we're we know each other you know
from comedy and stuff like that but
we're not super tight and so i was like
our outside perspective view was not
this well by
anybody i don't uh i talk a little bit
about it on stage but not at
i like touch on it because this is the
[ __ ] thing that's annoying about
stand up
because i like a lot of people's like oh
my childhood we drank water at the crick
and it's like funny
when i tell stories sometimes people are
so real yeah it's crazy
i don't want to [ __ ] hear this [ __ ]
i'm trying to chase salamanders yeah i'm
trying to eat a chicken wing in the
front row of a comedy club i don't want
to hear this [ __ ]
people crying yeah
holy [ __ ] oh god all right all right
i want to get into some more or do you
want to do some more background i don't
know
i mean i don't when i want to i want to
go back to one thing when did the woods
house come into play
was that the house right out of the that
was out of the apartment
into the woods okay into the woods what
kind of gun did he have out in the front
yard
he had a pistol and it was always this
thing of like
there was a vague threat that he was
going to use
that's true any of us he pointed at me
before yeah
and i have a bit about let's just i have
a bit about it
you guys know when you're hanging out
and your stuff that pulls a gun on you
that
i i have a bit of how i don't like guns
because and it's true there was a time
when uh
he made me shoot it with him which
sounds fun except for it was in
it was just us standing outside of the
woods shooting at the woods because he
was mad it's like
there's people like we don't know if
they're yeah somebody hiking shooting
mystery bullets what did i do is like
because it's like indiana it's like even
if it hit a guy he'd just be like
that's the price of freedom he's just
like
i deserve it oh that's what i get for
being around
did he have a collection of guns just
one gun i don't know one gun
is there anything else before we move on
to the questions this is what i'm
thinking i i don't i don't know where to
go
so you tell us is there anything else
you think
we need to know that's a good question
because it's so it's so broad that i
i think i think that's probably it i
think that gives us a good picture
yeah there's so much stuff that i like
came in like oh that's
something but then it's like not
childhood related but i i do a lot of
dirtbag [ __ ]
in my adult life but yeah as a kid it's
like that's
i think that covers most of it did you
guys eat at the red lobster
a fair amount that was still like kind
of a luxury but yeah some
one of the first meals i remember is
those cheddar bay biscuits
that's the first piece that i remember
wrong brother nothing wrong with those
babies
uh did you ever hang out at the red
lobster
while your mom was working like were you
like a worker no
i no although i think i do remember us
going there for dinner
and then they were short and then her
getting up and going to work
holy [ __ ] she would take whatever she
could get
i respect that though she's a hustler
yeah but now she's a nurse practitioner
she's doing well
yeah she has they kind of mellowed a
little bit and they're older oh you know
getting older
yeah i mean she still works the [ __ ]
load she has her own house
i just meant like with the guns and then
oh i don't know i
like i don't [ __ ] with that guy like i
don't like i try to keep my distance
uh i looked at he he his facebook popped
up
that guy's facebook is probably bonkers
and it was like live in bloomington but
i'm not a liberal
it looks like all right yeah
bloomington's hyper liberal
really bloomington is uh was like voted
the number one
like most gay friendly city in the world
in like
the early 2000s really and it's like
some people really like that and when i
go back it's like i hang out in the part
of town that's like that and then
but the the other half of the town is
not like that at all like
it's like when i was a kid our main
hangout was walmart like
that's the sort of town that i grew up
in and then the
city part is like super liberal there's
like sweaters on the trees and [ __ ]
like it's it's all knickknacks and [ __ ]
like it's all like little knickknack
stores
yeah like antiques and [ __ ] like yeah
it's like a it's an economy
well that's built for mother's day you
know
holy [ __ ] all right do they still live
in that same house
no uh so he does she has her own house
but they're still
uh like i said that's some [ __ ] i don't
wanna share too much because that's
their [ __ ]
all right then we'll go we'll go with
the do you remember the
street name of the apartment that you
were born in oh
it was uh it was like a it was a complex
for you know i think it was like
controlled
rent sort of [ __ ] and it was called park
slope
park slope what was the street that it
was on that i cannot remember maybe
highland park
or something like that what the [ __ ] was
that street that doesn't sound too bad
the name of it it doesn't
they name [ __ ] like that so that it
doesn't sound like oh you
might you have a 30 chance of dying yeah
in this neighborhood
not going to graduate
teenage pregnancy boulevard
stray bullet street all right you pushed
it
[Laughter]
go up from street you can't go back the
street he was giving me a look to like
i'm going to go for it
i was like don't do it i'm doing it
that's a classic h foley line doesn't
know when to get out
in slow motion look at toby
you were like me with gamestop it's like
we gotta get out
yeah yeah yeah yeah one too many i
apologize
um okay what was the name of the grocery
show that your mom went to growing up
kroger and i worked at that grocery
store
kroger nothing wrong with it detectable
institution would you do a kroger i
bagged groceries and pushed carts
and they thought i know like i get all
this [ __ ] but i
people in indiana thought i was mexican
i'm half indian sure my father but like
uh
they thought i was mexican and they were
like you're mexican you go push the
carts
so yeah it was crazy
[Laughter]
jesus because he's like the forest gump
of dirt balls
[Laughter]
he's experienced racism guns pulled on
him
he should be telling us this on a bench
somewhere waiting for a bus we're both
crying
i try to walk the country but i only i
just keep doing lubes around phoenix
sit next to a millionaire [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
all right
um yeah at first the pounder seemed
[ __ ] up and now it seems responsible
yeah it really does
this is my medicine i'm just i'm happy
it's not a fifth of [ __ ] you know
grandpappier this is like this is like
the first season a true detective where
matthew mcconaughey
was just sitting there crushing lone
stars or whatever that's what i feel
like is going on
we're not a lot of smoke in here but
i'll let you know
so you always want to talk about garbage
huh
on your cute little light swallower that
would
i should have just been dead-eyed into
the camera the entire time i mean
i'll tell you about garbage also the
questions i have like how many times a
week do you floss i didn't
i i thought i was going to be digging
for some stuff
did the okay i apologize no oh dude this
is fake
i just have to switch gears a little bit
we're just upset we're gonna have to
make room in the hall of fame for you
i mean literally one of my questions do
you ever wear a hard rock cafe t-shirt
oh i wish i was i came in playing ping
pong
we didn't go on vacation so yeah
uh we went to florida one time we went
to disney world it was a [ __ ]
nightmare
because we went for what do you mean i
can't bring my gun in here
your dad's fighting mickey
we stayed at uh we stayed at like a
motel on the way down it was like in a
con down
we drove from india i didn't fly until i
was in my 20s
holy [ __ ] you have a passport i do now
okay but i had to get it like
i had to get it to do montreal like i
never that was like one of the first
times i flew
so uh yeah i had to i didn't win
trying to take a big grab people around
me
what is this are we going to be okay
nothing is happening what in the future
we're still at the gate
[Laughter]
no i yeah we went to we went to orlando
to go to disney world what was the car
you drove down india
yeah it was an astro van it was uh that
is
i've gone on record months that's the
trashiest car
of all time seriously the astro funny we
thought it was sick when we got it we
were like
because most of my life or most of my
childhood we had been driving around in
my mom's beat up
uh honda civic and it was it had oh man
those astro vans they always smelt like
eggs
it did smell bad was it new at the time
it was not new
my mom we wouldn't well now my no we
would never buy a new car
that's that's you're just losing money
immediately
it loses uh 80 percent of its value the
second you uh touch it
that's such a tragedy yeah i know such a
where does such a dirtball metro you
didn't buy the astro van for the family
trip did you
not for the trip it was because well we
my mom had a kid
when she was like 40 like didn't know
she could still have a kid and then we
were like [ __ ] we need to we need more
room for your car yeah we're gonna need
a bigger van
but uh yeah we drive down there in that
everybody hates each other
by the time we get there i was 11.
all right uh i was in my like smart ass
age i had been watching a lot of like
boy meets world and i was like i got a
great program sharp tongue now i i had a
wit
you know and so i would say little smart
ass things that pissed my family off
uh and uh and so the whole time we're
fighting we stay in this hotel that has
roaches on the walls when we get in
there and we're like
we had to change hotels in the middle of
the night because we were just like this
is they're crawling on us it's [ __ ] up
oh my god
so we go to a best western and we're
like this is incredible they have a pool
we were that family the ones ruining the
pool
just the trash family who doesn't like
nobody wants them there of course
but luckily everyone's in jeans yeah
yeah
so you have to take your shoes off in
the hot tub these are my swimming
shoes
this is my swimming denim i don't want
my feet getting wet
i don't want my feet i don't want any
part of my skin touching this water
see my toes but i'm just dip
you go the one family member is just
like i just gotta dip my head in i'm
good
they're in there with a bottle of
shampoo
i'm just rinsing off darling but we went
to disney world it was like this big
thing we were looking forward to it the
whole week
it rains the whole day we're there for
like two hours and then we were supposed
to go the next day and my stepdad didn't
want to go so we just went to daytona
beach which was
it was fun but that's the only vacation
we ever went on i'm sorry
was the vacation two days there's two
days yeah you're joking
no we drove out you drove from indiana
drive
so i've had to do it in adulthood it's i
want to say it's like a
16-hour drive it took us two days to get
there wait you drove
two days to a vacation that was going to
be two days long
and then drove and then drove back two
days back yep yeah
you drove two days to go on vacation for
two days and then drove two days back
you didn't even stay at the place you
were supposed to go on vacation for the
two days no
and then drove to daytona beach yep here
are you garbage neo
dude he is the class is trying to hit me
damn maybe you should drink water
but i i was i was never a kid that went
we didn't go to disney world yeah i mean
we wanted to we would have our cousins
went stuff like that but it was just
never
it was just not going to happen yeah and
so some of this might be a little bit of
that biasedness but
i really think this is nothing against a
disney corporation
them marvel entertainment or any of its
subsidiaries
but disney world can really go wrong
because yeah expectation there's so much
on the table there's so much on the
table a lot of money
so much money at stake and it's just
filled with trash
it is it's bad it's just bad i've been
recently yeah i've been recently oh you
went recently yeah my
my mom uh and stepdad took all the
grandkids we uh they have six nieces and
nephews so she take
she took all the grandkids and i went
probably four years ago
it is tough yeah getting drunk and epcot
ain't nothing i wanted to put your nose
that's something i would do now i went
to
disneyland right before the pandemic
like
two weeks that's in california i was out
there for a little bit
and uh yeah it's like we were like maybe
it'll be like kind of dead because it
was like right when coveted with people
starting to talk about it yeah it was
before the nba got canceled we were like
maybe people will be scared
and then it was packed and like really
took forever to do anything
it's not my type of spot like i'm not a
ride guy
i like the rides i don't like a thrill
there's not much there for me yeah i
like all that stuff it's just there's
just something about like the anxiety
that's created yeah you know what i mean
for me everything i do and this is i
wish i could shake this
but everything i do i'm like am i
getting my money's worth like it was
really
pounded into me as a kid like we gotta
get our money's worth
like we would go to the buffet if you
didn't eat like five plates it's like
you're wasting the meal like it's it's
you're wasting money to not eat as much
as you can you're wasting money
if you don't waste as many rides if
you're waiting the wrong line for too
long you're like well [ __ ] we could have
just done this one later when it dies
down like that sort of and it's all i
wanted to go on the swings
yeah yeah it's always in my head like so
the whole time i'm like well this ticket
was 85
and the parking was whatever am i am i
having enough
what's an experience that you think is
worth the money that is a that's a good
question
anytime i go to a baseball game i'm like
that was worth it nice do you buy the
cheap seats and sneak down
but although i was just in phoenix and i
i [ __ ] because i used to do this in
chicago all the time
i would jog i would go i go i go to
baseball games alone all the time
because it's
like i don't have a day job so it's the
best when they have day games i'll just
go and have you know a couple drinks and
like
but i jogged there and i was always i
would always buy scalp tickets
like the second inning or whatever yeah
and i would get you know 30
uh like first base three rows back seats
and i tried to do that in phoenix this
weekend because i was like there's no
[ __ ] way
anybody i'm sorry to time this so i'll
we can change it around
out of here the curtain's been pulled
back
i was i was in phoenix this weekend and
uh the cubs were in town i'm a cubs fan
sure and i was like oh hell yeah and it
was game
five of the nba finals in phoenix i was
like
nobody's going to be there i'm going to
be living large the place is [ __ ]
packed with cubs
with cubs fans yeah and i it still cost
me like 50 bucks to get a decent seat
and i was like
but again fully worth it yeah i love
i love that uh what else is
totally worth it that's a good question
what i don't know that anything is
it jesus christ i don't know the ball
game's about 48.99
you know what's worth it uh the
playstation 5
because that i like something like that
where it's like i can just sit here and
waste my entire life
you can you can build up out it's not
it's not it's not it's infinite
right like it's like whatever you put
into it you're like it's it's an
all-you-can-eat buffet that you never
have to leave
yep because you keep doing this
whereas uh you know disney world that's
a strip club dance
the whole time you're like ticket runs
out what's a typical what's a typical
family buffet at the car house
i mean we would my me and my mom would
go to a chinese buffet
is like our number one thing or we would
be like because there was a chinese
buffet that opened in my town that had
crab legs
and that was like were i was really
weird that changed in my life
that was like our thing we would go and
uh just wait for the crab legs to come
out and it was like
heaven heaven we weren't like a golden
corral family really but
chinese buffets and i loved i love
chinese buffets take on american food
too
where it's like it's just like a piece
of pizza and a birthday cake and they're
like you're american
and i loved that [ __ ] it was like right
up my alley
that is that is what is worth it that
that is what is worth it it's a circle
backstreet
that is always worth it is like i also
love like a
uh not a benihana what's the place like
hibachi grills yeah that i mean i was on
the fence before
what i'm joking what the [ __ ]
jesus christ um okay
do you have any pets growing up
we had a dog and we had to give it away
because my stepdad kept feeding it beer
and like my mom was like we can't have
this
happening and then we got dogs when i
was a little older and then my mom has
dogs now
hold on well i'm sorry to interrupt you
yeah how old were you when you gave away
the first dog that was we were
i was like five and i was [ __ ]
devastated
i love the dog and my stepdad would be
like
he's an [ __ ] animals [ __ ] hate him
it's so funny we
every dog we ever got would just
growling i kind of get that too so
funny i think if i ever meet him i'll be
growling at him
but uh you should be a cia assassin
i mean we all agree on that right yeah
yeah i think uh
my i've every therapist i've had and i i
burn through them
they always quit on the spot they like
throw the folder down [ __ ] you
but uh they're always like uh if you
didn't have a good mom you would be dead
yeah yeah yeah you'd be dead or
murdering people yeah yeah yeah
you would you would have been the worst
doctor to ever live yep
you would have been drinking a white
claw like i don't know man your shit's
[ __ ] up
yeah your [ __ ] is all [ __ ] up we're
gonna make the first incision
here uh oh i miffed that
i'd say myth a lot
oh need a mulligan on it
[Laughter]
somebody tweaked the fentanyl i need a
neuralizer over here this guy's gonna
remember a goddamn thing
oh man okay you gave the dog away
so but then we we got uh we and we had
yard cats
like we had all these cats that would
just be in our yard and we would throw
food
all our leftovers would go to them so
they were kind of our pets
but yeah they were never
i've never heard the phrase yard cat now
yeah yeah
we yeah we had cats that would just roam
the area and we would uh we'd feed them
so they'd be hanging out out there all
the time
yard cats yeah we had we had like
turtles
we would find turtles in the road and
put them in a you know kiddie pool in
our basement
that's a good time in your basement
mm-hmm mm-hmm
i think that's a pretty easy that's
for some reason that was like a common
thing and i heard you're not supposed to
do that but
uh in adult age but you know i was a kid
i didn't know but yeah
we would you just see a turtle in the
road yeah it was getting run over a
million times and then you're like all
right i guess we'll put you in the
kiddie pool fill it
why did you have a kiddie pole in the
basement that's a good question
uh no yeah why did we have a kiddie pool
in the basement i don't think it was set
up
the whole time right that's it that's
what we could catch it we wouldn't film
we would put the kiddie pool on the
on the uh on the porch when it was hot
yeah whatever
yeah we were just gonna leave it outside
in the yard
you didn't have a regular pool i assume
oh no no
my stepdad where would the yard cats go
my stepdad's mom had an
above-ground pool and uh that was like
when she got that it changed our lives
we were like
uh in it all the time and uh it got
pretty gross
she was always like the one who would
like do [ __ ] my mom didn't want
us to have because she was like it's
dangerous she worked at the hospital she
would like
everything no trampolines or anything
this is yeah we had it
she this is a huge story i've been doing
i hate to i'm not trying to do my bit
but like
i have a bit about this because my mom
so vehemently didn't want to see the
trampoline because she she worked at
hospital so anything she wanted to do
she'd be like i see kids coming in here
all [ __ ] up like
you can't have this you can't have that
because she would see she was like you
never ride a motorcycle
uh you don't get a trampoline pools she
would just see kids get [ __ ] up from
them
so uh she uh my
my stepdad's mom was like these kids are
too sheltered they don't they need a
trampoline they don't have anything
you know and so when we were kids we had
this [ __ ] and so this lady who told you
you're going to hell right yes
okay and so she gets here's about a
broken arm he's [ __ ] spent an
eternity in [ __ ] hell
you might as well live it up yeah
he might as well live it up now young
man because you're gonna be cooking
so she gets us a trampoline day
one because it's not the one that has
like the net around it well the next the
nets didn't come around until like
early that's new mid mid 2000's this was
just a trampoline in the woods
like truly in the woods uh there was
like a clearing that we had it
immediately my brother i'm watching him
do this
he starts to float away from the he's
hopping on he's going really high he
starts to float away
and then just catches the side of the
trampoline and breaks his leg
immediately
and my her my grandma my step-grandma
hadn't told my mom she got the
trampoline and then had to call her and
be like you're not gonna be happy yeah
listen i got a trampoline it gets worse
dude once alabama gets the internet
you're gonna be the biggest comic on the
planet
yeah yeah they think i'm condescending
what was it
what'd you say i said they think i'm
condescending when i tell these stories
because i'm not telling them like
hey you remember how fun that was
what were the names of the pets what was
the pet that guy nicholas
was the dog the guy taken away nicholas
i know
it's not i didn't i don't think i named
him that'd be weird but
now when i think of it i think of the
schwarzenegger where it's like nicholas
uh which would have made sense nicholas
then we had like [ __ ]
which is a true hillbilly dog true trash
yeah
[ __ ] uh daisy is one now what are they
they're a rocky i named one
lucky uh who did not that's a car house
he did not
die in a lucky way drunk driving
he got two tuned up i told him i was
like give me your keys
well you know these dogs don't listen
you know he just said come on
take an uber the cop was like who let
the dogs out
that sucked no i like it anything out
dude a good doula
dog out reference come on yeah i like it
really fast just a quick aside i don't
know
please oh yeah yeah yeah did you know
that this is a safe space the floor is
yours did you know that out about this
recently who let the dogs out is a is
like a
horrific song because it's a it's not
about dogs at all it's about
ugly women at a party it's about ugly
women walking into a party and they're
like who let the dogs out
because it's like you're at a party the
rhythm was jumping and like they set the
stage and then just be like and then
these ugly [ __ ] show up it's
so mean it's so it's such a mean
thing yeah this is such a silly song i
know that was huge the kids were singing
yeah yeah it's like if all star was
about just like
horror
um all right let's see
you double join it i am double jointed
yeah
that's weird that you asked that how did
you yeah look at that that was like a
point of pride
all your fingers go back yeah i remember
being like this is cool
trick i have as a kid just a true freak
so yeah high school wasn't great
i was the kid who was like i'm double
jointed and i can juggle
double joint it's a tough look um anyone
in your family ever involved in a
class-action lawsuit
ooh that's a good question have they i
don't think
i don't think so i don't believe i don't
remember them ever talking about
anything like that because my
that is something that i could see them
chasing after but yeah
i don't uh i don't think anybody i'm
sure i have cousins
that have dabbled in or attempted to get
into the client pool
yeah wow yeah have you or any member of
your family ever hired a private
investigator for any reason
no no no not a private investigator
actually kind of yes i said that and
immediately had to take it back because
that's how
we found my father we had to find we had
to track my father down
to get child support and so it was kind
of like that it was a private
investigator
i didn't think of it like that at the
time but yeah that's what it was
sometimes you got to track your dad down
man he's somewhere
my god made dog the bounty hunter am i
right
uh anyone in your family owned their own
bowling ball no
we did actually when i was a kid yes my
stepdad had one
but that didn't travel that didn't we
weren't a family that like went out and
did [ __ ] like that yeah we we maybe went
bowling once when i was a kid
but that was like not yeah we didn't do
[ __ ] we just we watched tv and movies
that was like our
that was our uh recreational time okay
watch dukes the hazard in dallas that
was our fun
that's i was the kid at school trying to
talk about dallas
nobody wanted to have it i sounds crazy
i just started re-watching it
over the pandemic still kind of holds up
really yeah it ain't bad
i gotta i think i'm gonna re-watch this
as a kid it was like the first soap
opera
type thing i got into now who would
watch because me and my stepdad would
stay up and watch it
because it was on like nick it was like
the repeats
and it was like they would show them an
order and it was like the
first time my mom was like all right you
can stay up because it was on at like
10.
and that started a a long trajectory of
me
not going to bed at night i would just
watch tv until i
passed out and then uh yeah because i
got a tv in my room eventually but yeah
that was the first thing that's like oh
you can stay up if you're watching
[Laughter]
you're gonna dallas the fine uh artistic
stylings of dallas
you gotta stay up we gotta let this boy
watch dallas watching dallas with your
stepdad he smoked did he smoke
yeah like that guy the house yeah in the
house yeah it was
that was a thing i remember there was
like a turning point
in my childhood where i was like oh the
smoke's not bothering me anymore
yeah i remember because he would smoke
in the living room and the living room
was just down the hall from my bedroom
so you know how smoke travels and i
would just be up at night like
and then eventually i was like i can i'm
fine one floor house
yes well we had a we had a basement
garage actually
but it wasn't like we had an upstairs
bedroom situation the living room was
that and then
the basement was like just my step-dad's
area to go tinker around
what kind of cigs did he smoke do you
remember he smoked tomorrow
marlborough lights gentlemen
yeah he drank natty like everything was
light
yeah so he was healthy she's kind of a
fitness freak
[Laughter]
you know what's funny is like i ca i
can't imagine being an adult like
you know i like i work out and stuff my
stepdad the only thing i would ever see
him do that was exercise is he had a
john deere tractor
and sometimes he would just like pull it
up just
just to prove that he was still strong
oh my god hey deb i still got it
[Laughter]
a couple of food questions yes pack your
lunch in high school
or buy lunch it it went uh
event i started buying lunch uh i think
that was like an upgrade in our
uh finances at some point where i was
able to buy lunch because for a long
time i was a lunchable kid
and then really yeah i would do
lunchables
and then what was the other thing we
would have my mom would just pack like a
turkey sandwich
and uh in a mountain dew and uh a
mountain
yeah and we would have those like a
mountain dew
it would have mountains have you
listened to anything this guy said that
i was kidding we
did not drink water at all that was a
lot of the 90s
that was yeah yeah that's thank you okay
so it's nice i remember being like
people drinking water yes
my cousins it was only water at dinner
yeah without dude it was
brutal crazy i didn't start drinking
water until like four years ago yeah no
i'm the same yeah
yeah cause i was like who would do that
and then seltzer's kind of like was my
gateway drug to uh
all right but i've never met
or known or seen any kid
in the entire time that i went to school
yeah or i've ever even
heard of any child getting a mountain
dew
really no yeah we would have cans of
them
can of coke maybe yeah cans of mountain
dew and i remember there was a big
point in our i bet this happened when
you guys were kids too
where they came out with like if you
drink mountain dew it makes your penis
smaller yellow five and yellow six there
it is so what i didn't know that
that's how they got me let's start a
class action also that's what happens
i'm screwed
uh the the myth or whatever
i heard was it lowered your sperm count
yellow five and yellow six i remember
being like a [ __ ]
eight-year-old yeah i gotta lay off this
stuff meanwhile i'd hit puberty for
another 12 years
there's 22. i was so embarrassed by it
because i heard that
they said it made your penis smaller in
my school and so i would have a paper
cool
i think the principal comes over the air
uh today's tuesday
october 12th and stay away from mountain
dew and get a little pee-pee
like all throughout the country yeah
that mountain dew makes you
like does [ __ ] to your dick and i was
covering it with a paper towel when i
would drink it just because i didn't
want people to be like hey
look at old tommy small pig
okay uh have you ever worn axe body
spray
absolutely the commercials got it bully
got it
i was like i gotta have this and like it
was kind of embarrassing to ask your mom
to like
buy it because you're like hey i'm
trying to get some jail yeah i'm trying
to get laid over here
[Laughter]
i've covered myself in it and uh of
course it was disgusting and nobody
liked it that underlying baby powder is
sent to it
yep yeah but i was like this is gonna
change my whole life
i put a lot of stock
i was like this is going to change my
whole [ __ ] up
i put it on like a thinking i remember
because i got contacts at the same time
because at the time i was wearing
glasses i was like i'm wearing contacts
i got axe body spray
i'm about to hit different
people are gonna see that i'm built
different now yeah hater i love it the
underdog is on top
i put it all the time i was i was at my
house my sister had her friends over i
was probably
six whenever that came out early high
school maybe and they were like 21 or
whatever
and i like walked down with it on not
too impressive i was like going to the
movies or something
and i walked by like what is that smell
and i'm like oh god i brandon hopped in
the [ __ ] shower real quick
and it doesn't take it off yeah oh no
you gotta get power washed yeah
yeah how do you take your steak uh i
i like uh
i like it medium rare personally i like
i like to see it you know dancing
do you ever have caviar before oh i love
caviar
i had it for the first time at a buffet
because i would never think to work
this is my mom and i went to vegas with
my my sister
my sister loves vegas i've like i have
my own snakes
but we went and my mom's whole thing was
like we're going to this buffet
at bali's casino or whatever and we were
all like whatever it's like a hundred
bucks
to do it but that's the thing my mom was
looking forward to the whole time and
she was [ __ ] right
like they had caviar and like lobster
tails and [ __ ] and it was
so good i think it cancels out if you
have it at a buffet
yes it's true it's not like i like was
it like beluga it was like real cavity i
have no idea
it wasn't like the little orange eggs
they put on sushi no no no no this was
they were black
tom was eating bait he got a bag full of
power bait
i did get a hook in my mouth at one
point
okay i'm just gonna put this out here
now you are officially invited to the
are you garbage tournament of champions
isn't even the thing we've ever talked
about you're gonna you're right yeah
i got to go back to the drawing board
and come up with better questions than
you know have you had poison ivy as an
adult
i was gonna ask if you ever called
anybody mate
[Laughter]
man talking about showing up unprepared
now i know how the generals feel when
they play the globetrotters
this guy's bouncing balls off my head
honestly i i you legit flustered
and i was on my heels right away right
away
i literally he brought that in i'm like
oh he's trying to be guard like he's i
thought he brought the beer in to be
like
oh i'm going to try to ham it up because
i had no idea you had any of this
background if i'm doing a podcast i'm
going to have a [ __ ] [ __ ] what are
we doing here
oh okay that's what i blame the street
uh joke on that that didn't work
frazzliness just for the record and the
1989 joke didn't come out right either
and what what excuse you have for this
screeching hole
all backs that we had thankfully
forgotten i blame too much mountain dew
on all this
ever worn a lifeguard sweatshirt
no no we didn't have sweatshirts um
i got one now what you go home you got a
couple of coins you know you got a
quarter a nickel and a dime in your
pocket
what kind of container does that go into
that is going so right now what's your
current change jar right now
because i did i did the podcast douglas
movies and i stole one of the prizes
because it was uh because you have to
bring prizes when you do that somebody
had a pikachu
like coffee mug and so i was like that's
gonna be my new change
jar but you're there you were like
that's gonna be my that's mine
you stole it for that purpose i was like
maybe i'll try to drink coffee out of it
and then i tried once and it was not
built for that
and so i was like nah i'm just gonna
change change but i have also
next to that because you got a lot of
change i don't mean to break i'm doing
all right i don't want to brag
i got about 32 bucks but there's some
quarters in there
yeah some of those are quarters some of
them are european
i can't use them i got a button in case
i love it i have [ __ ] like that i've
like european i've never been to europe
i have like canadian i have canadian
like nickels and [ __ ] in my thing and
i'm like i better save that in case i go
back to canada
yeah when am i gonna dig through that
and like i
could get with i've been in a financial
position not too long ago where i've had
like forty dollars in euros or something
and like
went to the bank and been like i want to
change this like we don't do that here
and if we do we're gonna charge you like
25 transaction fees yeah
like you got to go to the airport you're
just sure you're not bringing that to
the airport they would arrest you i feel
like
what's this commie [ __ ] when you
chan when you get your change
we put it in we use a coin star or you
not use it because of the fee
uh i i always dreamt of using a coin
star
it's never a presence of mind thing it
looks so fun but
how do you use up do you roll your
quarters no it just sits there
okay i never do collect an interest yeah
yeah gaining value it's working for me
i never think in my head i'm like well i
need a quarter to go to the whatever
it's like
but it just sits there i i never think
to do anything with it it's been
yeah we have a change jar we haven't
touched in two years lived in the same
apartment
i got about 80 bucks in like a in a one
of the big like kind of like your water
bottle you have with the top cut off
and like that i that's in my net worth
when i do the math yeah i got one of
those folded like there
cut the top off how'd you cut it off
knife steak knife
probably i don't have a snake knife you
know it was like the sharpest knife i
have i guess
uh and that goes into my net worth when
i calculate what i have you're kidding
me
if i'm like oh i got a thousand dollars
in my bank account i go i got a thousand
eighty bucks on my back
i just agree yeah yep um before we get
into
now i just wanted to ask you did
you or your family have you guys did you
guys ever stand around and watch like a
house fire like watch the fire
department
put it out i would have or watch an
accident or anything like that as a fan
i've never chased an ambulance to see
where he's never chased an ambulance
uh i've done that personally i've just
watched like the fire department show up
in brooklyn but
in in our where we lived we were so
separated like
because we had like two acres or
whatever and then that's not bad it's
not that bad
yeah it wasn't bad but uh you know we
just had the direct neighbors right next
to us
and so and then across the street was
just farmland
like we like when if you like if you
walked out my front door
we have woods behind us and then across
the street it's just like
empty it's cows you know so and a man
with a handgun of course
my stepdad with a handgun yeah you're
gonna see that
you're gonna take a left at the man with
a handgun
he's going to be yelling at you he fires
once every
20 minutes just to feel some adrenaline
but uh
you're probably gonna miss that have you
been in the house and just heard like a
shot go off
uh yes yes uh i have
um because he would try to scare us into
thinking he killed himself
anyway it doesn't i don't want to go any
further who needs dallas when he got
that guy
talk about nick at night yeah but um
no but to you saying that about brooklyn
because the reason i thought of that
question is because
last night uh there was uh a manhole was
on fire
right in front of the 7-eleven near our
grocery store we were walking to the
grocery store
and all of a sudden there's a little
fire going on fire trucks pull up
about five minutes in the entire
neighborhood's out there
they got water rice going around people
are drinking
and we're all standing there like a
village of dirt bags
just watching the firemen i love that oh
dude
it's like a real new york moment i mean
the whole neighborhood's out there
yeah kids are running around balloons
and everything
fantastic time you got to take what you
can
you can get have you ever put ketchup on
mac and cheese we were talking about
this for the truck yes i have and i'm
going to tell you i stand by it it's
good
it's good it's great it's really good
it's great also
i'm going to say this mac and cheese
kind of sucks
it's overrated i don't know that's why i
put ketchup in it i put ketchup in it
because it's like i need something a
little
little tang to it yeah yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] i just lost all the audio
i maybe have some hot sauce i just don't
it depends on the mac and cheese but
it's like
oh man this is the trashiest thing i've
done what kind of brand was it when you
were growing up uh if we were lucky we
would have some craft but we weren't a
mac and cheese family
we were like uh we would buy frozen corn
dogs
and like that i learned to cook with
cook i learned to bake
uh like pizzas and hot dogs and [ __ ]
when i was like corn dogs when i was a
kid because my mom would work at night
so i had to feed all and my stepdad was
a drunk so i fed everybody
but i just i thought that i was like a
chef i was just throwing corn dogs on a
sheet pan and then that was that was a
lot of what we would if my mom was home
we would have like you know
chicken or whatever but like yeah we
didn't have a lot of that we had ramen
noodle soup a lot um yeah we weren't a
big mac and cheese
not a shitload of home-cooked meals we
when she was home we would do it but
it was a lot of hospitals it was a lot
of fast food i i
was i was like when wendy's introduced
the five for five
and they had the junior bacon
cheeseburger that was huge
like that was a lot of my meals were
just like having
four junior bacon cheeseburgers and then
some chicken nuggets how would you get
there walk could you walk or no that was
like if she was on the way home she
would stick it up
yeah she would stop and grab yeah you
couldn't walk anywhere like where it was
like it was it would take you like half
a day to walk to anything
where i lived like even the gas station
was probably
would have been like a 40 minute walk
jesus
hmm have you seen the sequel to boondock
saints
that is that is good
real fast i forgot this is i think this
this might be the trashiest form of food
ever and i just bought it two days ago
and my fiance is pissed because she saw
in the cabinet
they make flaming hot mac and cheese oh
yeah that's yeah i've seen that going
because i love anything flaming hot they
will they will sucker me on and that i
think is super trashy
trashy people love flaming hot because
it covers the flavor
of all the [ __ ] bad [ __ ] there sure yeah
you need hot sauce on everything
because your food is bad you know do you
still drink mountain dew
no okay actually i take that back i went
to taco bell the other day and i'll
drink
the uh you got to treat yourself
exactly it went in rome why is that that
how come only taco bell they've really
made it they've had to have a
big deal yeah because i would love to go
to mcdonald's and get a [ __ ] mountain
dew like it's not a coca-cola product is
it
uh no it's not it's pepsi right yeah so
they're probably
pepsi probably the only main brand the
only main
food chain that carries pepsi products
right oh really everybody else coke
probably has
crazy coke has burgers and coke has
mcdonald's coke has everywhere
that's [ __ ] yeah spread the word for
them though
yeah good for them also there's probably
a very big like if it was a venn diagram
of mountain dew drinkers
and [ __ ] taco bell people sure that
there's that's a there's
[Laughter]
it's right next to my gym and so often
i'll leave the gym and go to taco bell
what's your what's your favorite item to
talk about i mean i love the chalupa
it's it's so good but i don't get that
the flamin hot uh
or when they had it they had a flamin
hot uh dorito
um like shell taco yeah but now they
just have the regular or maybe it was
spicy nacho now they just have the
regular doritos locos i love that
and the quesadilla is you can't miss you
really can't [ __ ] up
it's all hits dude i [ __ ] love him
i honestly do man i love you
i he just got that was the most
passionate i've seen him in the past
hour and 12 minutes or whatever we're at
he really was like this i'm gonna pay my
masterpiece here i
food my fiance makes fun of me all the
time but it's like i obsess over
in fact coming here today i was like oh
[ __ ] i'm gonna go to chipotle after this
i was like so excited
or does toros they have here too but uh
uh
the wendy's spicy chicken sandwich as a
kid was like
that was like my form of happiness and
now the popeye's
spicy chicken is like god damn it i
think about it all the time dude i'm
right there
even just saying it now i got happy yeah
it fixes all the best
it really does it really does
that popeye's chicken sandwich dude is
[ __ ] it's
crazy that anybody is even trying and
yeah to be like
this is good i do want to try that
burger king one but because the pictures
look good he needs a dad when he got
chicken sandwich exactly oh
forget about all that guns pointing the
gun at you here's some
here's a spicy chicken well it sounds
like you got some projects you're
working on
[Laughter]
the way you said they were like you want
to try that burger yeah like if i can
get my i get my act together you know
get a couple yeah get on the straight
and arrow for a couple of weeks
i can just get my hands on one of those
okay okay kippy i got a guessing game
for you because i know you love them
sure in the year 2015 when baja blast
was introduced
how much did it generate in sales
for taco bell in a year in one year one
calendar year five million dollars
hold on let's i mean let's wait hold on
that's when it was introduced
i could swear about how blast had been
around for oh sorry this is this this
might be its most banner year this might
be the okay
i think baja blast has been around you
think you're gonna get that [ __ ]
come on he was there cutting the ribbon
with the big scissors
the day they popped that thing over that
he probably stole on the way home
this is good rib i'm gonna take this
ribbon wait cause i was at a wedding in
2009 at a taco bell
and i could have swore that they had
baja blacks all right
foley says five million five million oh
it's uh it's probably
[ __ ] 500 million dollars 500 million
i'm gonna say
oh i might say probably 500 million
dollars 500 million
and how much does that cost to make are
we counting is it
is it uh not profit it's yeah it's safe
sales
this is just sales this is uh in 2015
petseco reported that blah blast
brought in black 50 oh in sales for taco
bell since it was introduced
i'm gonna oh since it was introduced oh
no i apologize so this is
up to 20. and it's also what the sales
gen okay oh that changes everything this
is
up to 2015. so this is a report from
2015 since introduced i'm going to say
it was maybe introduced in like 2006 or
something because i
i think i was in high school when they
had it because i i worked mike kroger
was next to one and afterwards
kroger the girl guy worked at i'm pretty
sure
it sounds like he was on the board so
i'm gonna say 200 mil then
500 million yes i'm sorry i'd like to
change my answer 350 million dollars
do we go way too high way too low they
brought in a billy son holy crap [ __ ]
billy damn
that's what happens when you make a
fantastic product at a reasonable price
i'll tell you that right now get on the
patreon people
because hey they're not paying us all
right let's not forget because let me
tell you something the fountain
operations better taco bell whoa whoa
we're a better help family today
if i can read the schedule correctly the
fountain system at
taco bell is the elite one yes the ice
is perfect the
carbonation is always it's the only
place that i do that because mcdonald's
i everybody
i do like a diet coke from mcdonald's
but they [ __ ] up a lot too
they mcdonald's [ __ ] up more than
we're in for it now so there's a
mcdonald's next to my gym too and i get
i try to get
bla i drink where's your gym in the mall
food court what the [ __ ]
because jim's actually a walk-and-roll
yeah yeah so i've been working on it in
auntie anne's
yeah my gym is the delta terminal
i had no idea they so i try to get
i like uh my i like iced coffee i like
it black i don't i don't like to i
waste my calories on booze if i'm gonna
drink it so i don't like to
have calories in my my stuff i drink and
so i like iced coffee black and i like
mcdonald's coffee
every [ __ ] time i go to order at
mcdonald's and i try
i'm not rude i just try to be nice i'm
like hey i want ice coffee can i just
have it black nothing
they don't get that there's a full
conversation every time they're like
so uh cream and sugar like no black i
just want it black and there's like so
no flavor you wanted
to say no flavor
are you going to mcdonald's just for
coffee yes oh that's trash yeah i know
you live in new york city dude what are
we doing
it's so cheap it's like two bucks for a
giant one and it's uh it's convenient
except
every time we'll have that whole back
and forth and i'm like all right they're
definitely gonna get it this time still
give you an amber ride
yep yep it's just pure white they hit
the thing they hand me and i'm like no
yeah they don't get coffee and they're
always like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
why would you do this no flavor they
start to do it again
like they start well obviously you want
a little sugar yeah i'm like no
nothing yeah this guy doesn't know what
he's talking about that's crazy yeah
okay they act like i'm gonna be like
where's the whipped cream well this is
why because they've been beaten down so
much
by [ __ ] people being scumbags with
two things
ice uh-huh and [ __ ] those kind of
things i know and i just
that's why i feel bad i try not to be an
[ __ ] about it you have to beg for ice
yeah at like at any fast food place
because so many people are like not too
much ice yeah because they think they're
getting more
yes which is the most garbage reason
in the world yeah yeah extra ice
god damn i'm getting fired up get me a
truly what the [ __ ] get him a truly come
on
seinfeld
[Applause]
this is how outmatched i am for this
dude i'm done you ready
my next question was do you like
orangina
in high school in a french class there
was like a day
it was a it was a cultural uh [ __ ]
immersion class
they had they had pate and they had
orangina and i had french fries
it's an american drink it's not french
it was presented to me as this is what
french people drink
the pate was just hamburger helper yeah
it was a beef potato
stole that joke from someone oh my god
tom man this is
legendary yeah this is i mean we for
sure have to bring you back specifically
because there's so many
we have so many [ __ ] insane questions
that we have to get to from our patriot
like people when people sign up for
patreon
oh yeah yeah so we have so many insane
ones that we can't get to with certain
guests
but you're i mean he should come in like
once every like six weeks and just clean
up
all the insane questions that we have to
get through well i'm like i can't ask
andrew schultz if like his stepdad ever
shot a guy
listening to uh the one with cannon i
was like god dammit there's so many that
i was like ah
like the craigslist thing i spent so
much time on craigslist
that's for another day
i i used to like scour i used to i
thought it was funny when i was in
uh college to post fake craigslist ads
as a man
as a woman for men because i was like i
would just read insane ones so i would
post like
looking for somebody to uh [ __ ] me on my
dad's grave or whatever
and to see if guys would still respond
and then they did yeah of course
crazy dick pics oh a million yeah a
million i've seen every shape and size
this kid's a real cool cat huh yeah
weird flicks i wonder why [ __ ] high
school was hard on the kid
um all right i gotta call i mean i you
know
run through a couple of patreon there we
go we gotta wrap this one's just a funny
question this is from brandon have you
has a family member ever offered you a
seasonal beer in the wrong season
that's a whole other way as [ __ ] i will
tell you nobody's done that to me
i've done that to other people because
when i lived in chicago
there was a target by me that had a
brooklyn
pumpkin ale for two dollars a six-pack
so i bought the whole [ __ ] thing i
had like 26 packs
of brooklyn uh a brooklyn pumpkin and
it's
summer like it's not
yeah so we lived together and we would
we had the dirt bag at that [ __ ]
place we had
after i left everybody got bed bugs and
[ __ ] like it was dirty in there is that
the one where
our curry was in the basement no that's
in
that was in new york uh this was in
chicago uh
in chicago we did this we had our fridge
full of it and it was one of those end
of the night
we didn't have any other beer we would
all just start chugging those and hated
every [ __ ] sip but it was like
a staple of our apartment for a while
where people would come over and be like
god damn it like i guess we're drinking
the [ __ ] pumpkin beer cause it's
three in the morning you can't buy beer
anywhere oh that [ __ ] stinks
but tim would always just so angrily be
like
like just watching him begrudgingly
drink of pumpkin ale is like
that's what chicago still is to me it's
just a dirt bag
i've had a lot of like july oktoberfest
from the previous year yeah yeah i mean
we got christmas budweiser's in the mini
fridge right here yep
pumpkin ale pumpkin is a specific i'll
never drink it again
because of that it [ __ ] it up for me
it's skunked pumpkin ale oh
i like it you have very infomercial
studio audience energy when you talk
about prices
two dollars that's my childhood bro it's
two dollars
oh all right uh this one's from doo doo
69
i don't know if that's his government
name uh oh my mom
did you have a senior yearbook quote if
so what was it no
my god that's a homework that's a great
good one i don't think i did we didn't
have
i didn't even get my senior yearbook
that was one of those things where
my family's like you'll remember it just
try really hard holy [ __ ]
i remember mine mine was a jethro tulle
lyric ooh spin me back down the years in
the days of my youth
i will if i had you think you're so deep
but especially as a high school kid
everybody does yeah if i'd had one it
was probably like a [ __ ] like tupac
lyric or something
hell yeah people are gonna think this is
really cool in the view
i had a tupac jersey that i would wear
at school and i thought people would
think it was cool and like cool man i
know that exactly
yeah yeah that's a bad look yeah it was
bad it was bad
um all right then this one's from tony p
is it garbage to write your initials
on wet concrete in front of your own
house yes
we did it when we got our pool we did uh
like our hands and like
the date and stuff like that that's on
your property though that's a little bit
different if you're doing it on the
sidewalk yeah
sidewalk yeah i i would say
yes yeah oh it's true because it's one
of those like i need to be immortalized
yeah in concrete did you ever
ever carve your initials into the into a
tree with your high school sweetheart or
anything i didn't have a high school
sweetheart
uh i would have loved to trust me
brother i drove takers on craigslist
i dreamt of doing that but i uh yeah i
never did that
tom and mountain dew forever tom and bob
and two dollar beers
tom loves pumpkins all right i mean i'm
i'm [ __ ] gassed we got to have you
back for a
man i would love to come back blown away
i'm blown away this was an absolutely
fantastic episode uh unbelievable
but troy i mean we're he's oh okay i
mean jesus all right just for the record
we gotta get it on table i mean
you're the garbage i think this is the
most
like deep flavored garbage
ever yeah it's unbelievable it was the
the most insane thing i felt like punch
drunk at the end of it
in the face well every question you ask
he introduces someone else another
setting
and that then leads to another thing it
was like a [ __ ] christopher nolan
movie
i feel like i was watching garbage
tenant or something like that half of it
was going backwards i didn't know what
was going on unbelievable man yeah thank
you so much
what do you got the folks out there to
know you got caught up in anything uh
thanks so much for having me boys i love
you guys pod it's [ __ ] hilarious
i'm happy to be a part of it it was so
fun but uh yeah i got uh follow me on
instagram i'm going to be posting a
bunch of clips and stuff but it's tom
takar it's t-h-a k-k-a-r and uh yeah i
have a bunch of clips coming out
my podcast is called stand by your band
to do it with tommy mcnamara we gotta
have you boys on for sure
you defend music that uh people make fun
of you for liking it's like a lot of
like trashy [ __ ] of course like uh you
know
creed or nickelback or [ __ ] uh it's it's
super fun
and then uh yeah find if you can find my
[ __ ] half hour special on comedy
central please watch it
because if i try to post clips from it
they [ __ ] stomp it down really
yeah and i also have a podcast with them
that's over now but it's called stand up
with the
time to car that's i mean the episodes
are still up so it's cool
and then yeah just social media [ __ ] tom
takar awesome
we love you buddy absolutely super funny
super fun thanks man and this was
something else kippy what do you got for
him uh as always please make sure you
rate view subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube
uh patreon.com you can sign up you get
bonus episodes of ayg
uh you get episodes of hard feelings
which is me and foley mixing it up and
we do a live stream every month with our
top tier patrons
and then live shows guys we're [ __ ]
boston's almost sold the [ __ ] out
rhode island's [ __ ] cooking we have
probably like what seven or eight more
dates for cities we're announcing
get ready it's gonna be a [ __ ] good
time yeah i'm gonna go home take a
shower
and call my parents yeah tell them how
much i love them guys we love you we'll
see you next week peace